I recently read across a product, a salicythium.
So salicythium is a glycobenza aldehyde.
So aldehyde is a classification of organic compounds.
And glycobenza aldehyde is a type of aldehyde
that can help block the glycolysis pathway.
So that's where salicythium ranks.
Now, salicythium, I have read about it years ago.
There's an article about it in the Townsend newsletter.
It's an alternative newsletter.
It has a lot of cancer information in it
that I read about a number of years ago.
I don't care if it's an expensive product.
And I just have not carried it in our store.
And I have it tested for it.
I did have a bottle years ago, and it first came out.
And I used to test for it.
It didn't test very well.
It ended up expiring it.
I got rid of it.
And I just, we'd ever ended up carrying it.
I never wrote them under the book
because I never really got it to use it.
But I don't think there's anything wrong
with trying something like that.
So it has become more available at that time
when I was looking at the only place you could get it
was New Zealand.
And, or Australia, I was off-stralier
to New Zealand.
I couldn't remember where we could get it.
But it was difficult to get.
I think it's maybe easier to obtain that.
But I don't know a whole lot more about it.
But I know it works on the glycolysis pathway.